>>> PLUS THEY EXPLAIN TO
CONGRESS WHY THEY CONVINCED THEM
AN ATTACK WAS NOT COMING.
>>> WE BEGIN WITH A PRESIDENT
AND HIS ANXIOUS PARTY.
THE STAKES ARE SIMPLE.
STRIKE A DEAL IN THE NEXT 24 TO
36 HOURS OR WATCH THE CHINA
DEAL, HEALTH CARE, CHILD CARE,
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPLODE.
HOUSE LIBERALS SAY THEY WANT THE
GOVERNOR TO SPEND AND DO TOO
MUCH.
HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI IS
TRYING TO BUY THE PRESIDENT SOME
TIME AND SPACE.
QUOTE, DON'T BE MAD AT THE
PRESIDENT, BE MAD AT ME.
SO WE WAIT AS KEY PLAYERS GET
MORE WHITE HOUSE ATTENTION AND
AS THE CLOCK NOW TICKS ON A
THURSDAY HOUSE VOTE FOR WHAT
SHOULD BE A SLAM-DUNK, AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN THAT WOULD
FIX ROADS, BRIDGES AND CREATE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS.
LIBERALS SAY THEY WILL VOTE NO
AND THEY WILL TANK IT IF THE
PRESIDENT FAILS TO GET THE
BIGGER DEAL DONE.
LET'S GO TO MANU RAJU ON CAPITOL
HILL.
MANU, THIS IS A HUGE DAY OF
CONSEQUENCE FOR THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS PARTY.
>> Reporter: YEAH, AND THE
QUESTION IS WHAT HAPPENS FROM
HERE AND UP TILL TOMORROW, AND
WE JUST DON'T HAVE CLEARANCES AS
OF YET.
THERE IS STILL A MAJOR DILEMMA
FACING SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI AS
WELL AS JOE BIDEN ON HOW EXACTLY
TO ASSUAGE PROGRESSIVES WHO ARE
THREATENING TO SINK THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE TOMORROW.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE ASSURANCES OR
SEE THE LARGER BILL TO EXPAND
THE SOCIAL SAFETY NET MOVING
ALONG IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS.
THERE ARE STILL NEGOTIATIONS
ONGOING, INCLUDING AT THIS
MOMENT, NEGOTIATIONS WITH
KYRSTEN SINEMA AND JOE MANCHIN
TRYING TO GET THEM TO SEE A WAY
FORWARD.
NANCY PELOSI THINKS THERE NEEDS
TO BE MORE LANGUAGE IN THAT
LARGER BILL TO SIGN OFF BY THE
PRESIDENT ON THURSDAY.
BUT AS YOU CAN SEE HERE, THAT'S
AN INCREDIBLY HIGH HURDLE AS KEY
SENATORS LIKE JOE MANCHIN HOLD
OUT.
>> I THINK IF WE COME TO A PLACE
WHERE WE HAVE AGREEMENT IN
LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE, NOT JUST
PRINCIPLE, IN LEGISLATIVE
LANGUAGE THAT THE PRESIDENT
SUPPORTS, HAS TO MEET HIS
STANDARD.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
SUPPORTING.
THEN I THINK WELCOME TOGETHER.
>> Reporter: SHE SAID THEY NEED
LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE AGREED TO.
>> THAT WON'T HAPPEN.
>> Reporter: HE SAID THAT WON'T
HAPPEN, GETTING A LEGISLATIVE
DEAL BY TOMORROW.
THAT'S WHAT THE PROGRESSIVES
WANT.
THEY WANT THAT BILL THAT MANCHIN
WILL SIGN OFF ON, SINEMA WILL
SIGN OFF ON, AND NANCY PELOSI
SAID SHE WILL NOT BRING UP THE
LARGER BILL IN THE HOUSE UNLESS
THERE IS AN AGREEMENT WITH THE
SENATE.
MANCHIN MADE A POINT TO ME.
HE SAID, ALL WE NEED TO DO IS
SIGN THE INFRASTRUCTURE DEAL AND
SIT DOWN IN GOOD FAITH.
THE PROBLEM IS THE PROGRESSIVES
WANT THAT BIPARTISAN BILL TO BE
STALLED AND THEN THEY WANT THAT
OTHER LARGER BILL TO MOVE
FORWARD FIRST.
JOHN, UNCLEAR HOW THIS GOES.
AT THE MOMENT THAT VOTE IS
SCHEDULED FOR TOMORROW, BUT IT
COULD ALSO BE DELAYED.
>> THERE IS TRUST DEFICIT WITHIN
THE DEMOCRATIC FAMILY.
WE WILL WATCH AS THIS BIG DAY
PLAYS OUT.
MANU, WE APPRECIATE THE LIVE
KICKOFF.
WE HAVE CHIEF INTERNATIONAL
AFFAIRS ANALYST, KASIE HUNT.
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT NOW.
HE HAS A STAFF GOING TO SEE
SENATOR SINEMA AGAIN. SHE WAS AT
THE WHITE HOUSE, I THINK, THREE
TIMES YESTERDAY.
THE OPTIONS ARE SIMPLY GET A
DEAL TODAY, WATCH YOUR AGENDA
IMPLODE TOMORROW OR SOMEHOW
CONVINCE EVERYBODY TO TAKE A
TIMEOUT.
THE PROGRESSIVES SAY THEY WERE
MADE A PROMISE.
>> AND THE REALITY, JOHN, THEY
DON'T HAVE TREMENDOUS AMOUNTS OF
TIME GIVEN THEY HAVE TO PUT THE
DEBT CEILING ON THE GOVERNMENT
AND PUT THE SCREWS TO THE TWO
SENATORS.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT DOES
KIRSTEN SINEMA WANT?
THERE SEEMS TO BE A REFUSAL TO
SAY WHAT SHE WANTS THAT LEADS
THEM TO THIS POSITION.
USUALLY IN THESE SCENARIOS
WRITING LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE
HAPPENS LITERALLY MINUTES BEFORE
A FINAL BILL IS PASSED, SO THAT
SEEMS LIKE A BIT OF A STRETCH AS
A POSSIBILITY.
>> THAT'S AN INTERESTING POINT
YOU MAKE, BECAUSE LET'S SEE IF
THAT CHANGES OVER THE NEXT 24
HOURS.
THEY WANTED A LEGISLATIVE BILL,
THE WAY IT'S WRITTEN SO
EVERYBODY COULD READ IT.
THAT COULD BE THE WIGGLE ROOM
THERE, BUT YOU MENTIONED SENATOR
SINEMA.
THREE TIMES AT THE WHITE HOUSE
YESTERDAY, AND AIDES ARE COMING
TO HER TURF TO NEGOTIATE MORE
WITH HER TODAY.
THEY'RE GOING THROUGH WHAT DO
YOU WANT IN THE BILL, AND THEN
ADD IT UP.
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST?
NO.
WHAT DO YOU WANT THE COST TO BE?
THEY'RE GOING BACK AND FORTH.
THIS IS RO KHAANA, A KEY MEMBER
OF THE PROGRESSIVES, SAYING WHY
DOES ONE SENATOR GET TO HOLD UP
EVERYTHING?
>> THIS IS THE ENTIRE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY AGAINST JOE BIDEN AND
KYRSTEN SINEMA.
I DON'T THINK SHE KNOWS WHAT SHE
WANTS, I DON'T THINK THE
PROGRESSIVES KNOW WHAT SHE
PRESIDENT KNOWS WHAT SHE WANTS,
I DON'T THINK HOUSE MODERATES
KNOW WHAT SHE WANTS.
LET'S NEGOTIATE.
LEET COME UP WITH A DEAL.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND IT.
>> IT'S WASHINGTON, IT'S
DYSFUNCTION, NOBODY HAS DONE
SOMETHING THIS BIG.
BUT SENATOR SINEMA THINKS SHE
CAN GET A BETTER DEAL
NEGOTIATING WITH THE PRESIDENT
IN THE WHITE HOUSE THAN IF SHE
GETS IN A ROOM WITH ALL THE
PROGRESSIVES, BECAUSE THEN
YOU'RE HORSE TRADING.
THE MORE PEOPLE IN THE ROOM, THE
MORE COMPROMISES.
SHE THINKS SHE GETS A BETTER
DEAL THIS WAY.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S CLEAR THAT
WHAT SENATOR SINEMA WANTS THAT
WE CAN SEE IS CONTROL.
WE DON'T NECESSARILY KNOW WHAT
POLICY SHE WANTS, BUT I THINK
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR SHE WANTS
CONTROL, SHE WANTS TO BE ON THE
FRONT LINE, SHE WANTS TO BE A
KEY PLAYER AND SHE WANTS TO BE
ABLE TO SAY TO YOUR POINT, I'M
THE ONE THAT WENT TO THE WHITE
HOUSE AND GOT SOMETHING DONE,
AND WHAT I GOT DONE IS WHAT GOT
PASSED.
AGAIN, I THINK THE QUESTION IS,
WHAT IS SHE PUTTING IN THE BILL,
WHAT IS SHE TAKING OUT, AND
SHE'S NOT REALLY BEING
TRANSPARENT ABOUT THAT THUS FAR.
>> THE TRANSPARENCY PART IS KEY
IN THE SENSE THAT WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS SAY BEHIND THE SCENES
THEY'RE MAKING PROGRESS WITH
HER.
THEY SAY THEY ARE.
WE'LL SEE IF THEY GET THERE.
THAT WOULD AT LEAST GIVE THE
EVIDENCE THEY THINK IT'S WORTH
THE CONVERSATION.
YOU SEE RO KHAANA SAYING WE HAVE
NO CLUE.
THIS IS JOSH GOTTHEIMER, ONE
THAT'S MORE CENTRIST, SAYING
DON'T WORRY, EVERYTHING IS OKAY.
>> EVERYBODY IS WORKING AROUND
THE CLOCK, INCLUDING SENATOR
SINEMA.
I'M GETTING IT DONE.
SHE WAS IN THE WHITE HOUSE
YESTERDAY.
I WASN'T IN THAT MEETING.
WE JUST KNOW GREAT PROGRESS WAS
MADE AND WE'LL CONTINUE TODAY.
>> AGAIN, IF THE PRESIDENT CAN
NEGOTIATE DOING IT THIS WAY,
THAT'S AN AMAZING ACHIEVEMENT
FOR HIM.
EVERYONE ELSE IN THE PARTY, AT
LEAST MOST EVERYONE ELSE IN THE
PARTY IS PRETTY RAW BECAUSE THEY
THINK THEY'RE OPERATING BLIND.
>> BECAUSE THEY ARE OPERATING
BLIND.
CONGRESSMAN GOTTHEIMER WAS ALSO
MADE A PROMISE, AND THAT'S A
VOTE ON THIS INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
ON THURSDAY.
LIKE MANU SAID, IT CAN ALWAYS BE
MOVED BACK, BUT THERE ISN'T A
LOT OF PRESS, AND YOU HAVE TO
ASSUME PROGRESSIVES ARE GOING TO
FALL IN LINE ONCE THEY DO SETTLE
ON NOT ONLY WHAT SENATOR
SINEMA'S NUMBER IS, BUT WHAT
KIND OF DEALS SHE'S MADE.
ARE THERE GOING TO BE RED LINES
WITH THE BERNIE SANDERS SET THAT
HAVE BEEN TAKING OUT?
WE JUST DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT, BUT PROGRESSIVES HAVE MADE
IT CLEAR THEY DON'T WANT TO LOSE
THEIR LEVERAGE.
THEY THINK IF THEY VOTE ON THE
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE BILL,
THAT LEVERAGE IS GONE.
>> AND LIKE CONGRESSMAN
GOTTHEIMER SAID, PROGRESSIVES
WON'T BACK DOWN.
WE'RE FIGHTING THE PEOPLE'S
FIGHT AND WE'LL VOTE FOR THE
BUILD BACK BETTER BILL.
THEY DON'T TRUST THAT IF THEY
VOTE FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL, SENATOR MANCHIN AND OTHERS
WON'T JUST WALK AWAY.
THEY THINK IF THEY DON'T GET
THIS NOW, THEY DON'T GET IT AT
ALL.
>> BECAUSE THE REALITY IS LOOK
WHAT IS HAPPENING.
THESE TWO SENATORS, MANCHIN AND
SINEMA, THEY ARE AT THE WHITE
HOUSE.
THEY'RE SAYING, OKAY, THERE IS A
PLACE WE CAN GET WHERE WE WILL
VOTE FOR THIS.
THEY NEED EVERY SINGLE VOTE IN
THE SENATE.
AS YOU POINT OUT, IF, IN FACT,
THIS INFRASTRUCTURE BILL IS OFF
THE TABLE, THEN THEY SAY, NEVER
MIND, NEVER MIND, DON'T WANT TO
DO IT AT ALL.
THE CHALLENGE HERE IS IF THEY
HOLD OFF LONG ENOUGH, THEN
DEMOCRATS ARE POTENTIALLY LEFT
WITH NOTHING AT ALL TO SHOW FOR
IT.
I THINK BY THE DAY THE PRESIDENT
SEEMS TO BE FACING NEW
CHALLENGES, WHETHER IT'S POLLING
NUMBERS THAT ARE COMING OUT OF
PLACES LIKE THE IOWA POLL FROM
LAST WEEK THAT REALLY STUCK OUT
TO ME WHERE HIS APPROVAL RATING
HAD REALLY DROPPED.
THE ECONOMY IS SHOWING SIGNS OF
SHAKINESS THAT SOME OF THE
MODERATE DEMOCRATS I TALKED TO
IN CONGRESS ARE REALLY
CONCERNED, ESPECIALLY HEADING
INTO MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
IT'S NOT LIKE THE ENVIRONMENT IS
MAKING THIS ANY EASIER.
EVERY DAY THAT GOES BY, IT GETS
HARDER.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S NUMBERS ARE
DOWN, ANYWAY.
COVID IS UP, AND WHAT'S GOING ON
ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
IN APRIL IT WAS 88.3.
AMERICANS WERE FEELING PRETTY
GOOD ABOUT THE DIRECTION.
EARLY IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THEY THOUGHT
COVID WAS GETTING BETTER, THEY
THOUGHT THE ECONOMY WAS GETTING
BETTER.
LOOK AT THIS NUMBER NOW, 70.3,
FROM APRIL TO AUGUST.
NUMBER TWO, THAT NUMBER, IF IT'S
BELOW 80, THE INCUMBENT PARTY
NEEDS TO WORRY.
IF IT GETS BELOW 70 -- IT WAS 68
IN 2010.
THE MIDTERM OF THE OBAMA
PRESIDENCY, THEY LOST VOTES.
THIS IS YOUR FUTURE.
>> THAT'S WHY THE GOVERNMENT
SAYS WE NEED TO DO THE SOCIAL
CHANGE PACKAGE BECAUSE THERE'S
SO MUCH IN IT THAT THEY THINK
PEOPLE WILL LIKE IF IT HAPPENS.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
PROGRESSIVES, THAT THEY CAN'T
WIN IN THE MIDTERMS WITHOUT THIS
LARG